so don't if you've heard but tomorrow is
the first time that rocket company
SpaceX will be sending real human
astronauts up into space tomorrow's
launch out of Kennedy Space Center will
see NASA astronauts Bob Behnken and Doug
Hurley getting inside SpaceX's crewed
raggin capsule which will be launched on
top of a falcon 9 rocket up into space
which will then accelerate them up to
the 17,000 miles an hour needed in order
to enter into the same orbit as the
International Space Station which they
will then dock with about 19 hours later
and then once they're there the
astronauts will be on board the ISS for
a couple of months before returning back
to earth on board that same crew Dragon
capsule so this is a huge deal for a
number of reasons first of all is the
first time in almost a decade that the
US has sent astronauts into space
entirely under its own steam but more
importantly this is the first time that
a private company is providing the
technology to do so so this is really
the dawn of a brand-new era of space
travel and I think it is so amazing so
make sure you tune in to the live stream
tomorrow because this really is a major
step on our way to Mars and we all know
the real reason why that's important
steamy lush globe's
and barely habitable celestial objects
are drifting through the void just we